things are a little different today
first of all I couldn't get through the
opening without completely falling apart
second
um Mr Gourley is not joining us today I
know yeah uh he's uh he's got other
matters he needs to attend to but that's
uh maybe good news because it means we
get to spend a little time with my
assistance assistant David hopping hi
David Hi how are you I'm good how are
you uh very good you of course picking
up the slack for Sona who's now an
author podcaster uh mother of two twins
and uh so there's some things she can't
get to and you you dash into the breach
and take care of it I think we're a good
team yeah she had to help uh drive a
prescription to you I did I was out of
town I did a thing I did something you
did you got me a prescription yeah and
now everyone knows I'm addicted to drugs
we everything's a lot everybody assumed
it also you made me sound a lot busier
than I am it's not that I'm so busy it's
just that I kind of don't want to do it
anymore yeah but I think that David is
just really he's still got that youthful
vigor in him yeah you know you have you
still insist on the same amount of money
if not more exact same yeah and I'd like
a race
well uh David
um you're a very young fellow thank you
uh you know sona's getting on in years
wow no no no I'm in that in the nicest
way you did yeah you're aging rapidly uh
you know you look amazing um but of
course I'm ancient you are how old uh
30. okay you're a young man you're
plugged into what's happening and just
before we started recording you've got
some exciting news that totally
mystified everyone in the room what is
it everyone no I was just looking you
were like what are you looking at on
your phone and I said
um Jamie Lynn Spears just announced a
Zoe 101 reboots okay what's a Jamie Lynn
Spears um Britney's Fair sister okay and
what uh what a reboot of what this is
the Nickelodeon show she was on Zoey 101
never heard of it before uh you really
missed out
um
you had a a younger daughter like didn't
she was not she didn't watch Zoey 101.
okay Zoey 101 yeah no she never watched
so we wanted to like went to a school
uh-huh no I don't think my daughter ever
watched Zoey 101 okay
um my daughter was a big
Hannah Montana fan uh uh my daughter's
now 19 and I remembered when we told her
we were moving out to Los Angeles we
lived in New York and we're doing the
Late Night show and we're gonna move to
LA
she burst out crying she said I don't
want to go I don't want to go I want to
stay here in New York and we were like
well we kind of have to go and then
thinking on my feet I said guess who
lives in LA
Hannah Montana and my daughter said hmm
okay and I'm I did lie I did make it
seem like we were going to see Hannah
Montana all the time oh did you ever did
she ever I did actually go to a store
and uh um I was in the store and someone
approached me this is had Fred after I'd
been in La for about nine months or a
year Miley Cyrus comes up to me and she
said oh hi you know I follow you on
Twitter and I said oh hi it's so nice
and then I thanked her I said you're the
reason we were able to get our daughter
to uh Los Angeles and I told her the
story and she said well I'm glad I could
do you that that's solid because it was
her and her alone yeah not you or your
career didn't give a about any of
that just just yeah but so so she knew
about Hannah Montana uh Zoe 101 then
they're gonna reboot it now Jamie Lynn
Spears I'm guessing now she's about 55.
she can't be in the Zoe 101 reboot
unless she plays an old Korean War of
that what how is that going to work I
don't know it that's all I know okay
posted Paramount plus I guess okay but
you don't know new things we know we
have already establish this like do you
know the name of Taylor Swift's new
album oh
I do okay what is it red no that was
like before Five albums ago
um show me what you got no that's never
been one
um I think if you keep going you're
gonna get there moon glow
we're getting closer
[Music]
making it with what you got
laughs
station 54.
somebody give him a hand hold it I think
I got it
moon dragon the next chapter the next
next chapter yeah so there's already she
released an album called moon dragon and
this is the next chapter this is the
next chapter and I know this I know
Taylor is recutting all of her music
yeah uh so this is all this is the stuff
that you saw on Babylon 7000. this is
all been redone for moodragon the next
chapter
plus three new tracks gotta be here oh
go in the distance
and shaznak
the Gaba ghoul story
so don't get in my grill about not
knowing about yourself
you're a Swifty yeah
um I think that you your air is the 90s
is that right yeah I was born in 92.
okay and so you are I know you're
obsessed with pop culture from the 90s
and 2000s is that right sure I am so I
must have been a huge impact on you oh
yeah three four five six well I was one
when you started your show yeah I know
but a lot of one-year-olds were tuning
in to see what was they were just left
me in front of the TV
um when you got a job with me you didn't
care about me at all I cared about you
no you didn't the way you said that if
you had a channel your voice got high if
you had it shared about it if I cared
about you hey if it had been a choice
between interning for me or for Britney
Spears Britney Spears
yeah
it's important that we're honest it's
not okay but you totally would have sold
me out to go work for Britney Spears
yeah do you have a contact now
can you get him can you give me a job is
she looking for an assistant I I don't
know but no yeah I would have gone to
Brittany over yeah I know you said that
you don't have to hit that reiterate
yeah Britney Spears over Conan O'Brien
yeah right yeah yeah the choice oh yeah
yeah and what's your favorite Britney
Spears song you tell me and I'll tell
you
probably lucky yeah that's a great one
how's it go yeah what a lucky don't you
wish that you knew I'm gonna come back
because I like this beef to I saw you
and you saw me together we're gonna
raise some bumblebees and make honey
you didn't even say lucky
I want to die right now
if I could take my own life all I have
is this pen that won't do the trick I
would do it right now
um I'm excited about our show because
first of all I just named a bunch of
songs and albums that Taylor Swift
should make
the gamma ghoul story is the one I'm
gonna be excited about I know that she'd
have a great whole
seven great songs about cured Italian
Meats